we turn now to the latest on the
recovery efforts in louisiana where many
people still have no power after
hurricane ida and roughly 760 000 people
are either without water or being
advised to boil water long lines are
forming in the sweltering heat for
critical supplies like food and gasoline
rescuers are still trying to make
contact with people who have not been
found our lead national correspondent
david begno is in hard hit laplace
louisiana david good morning
good morning buddy let me tell you
something the sunrise is beautiful but
the reality on the ground is still rough
aside from looking for food and fuel and
a place to sleep the elements are
miserable the bugs are incredible i mean
look we saw a family sleeping outside
their car yesterday and the
six-month-old baby with the family was
just covered in bug bites shantae let's
take the drone now if you take a look at
where we have the floodlight position
you can see the flood water in front of
this motel 6 in laplace louisiana and
there was a sheriff's deputy who pulled
up a short time ago and told our crew
fyi guys alligators were displaced in
this area and so you need to be careful
that you don't run across one
that
may sound ridiculous but at the end of
the day that's part of living in
louisiana especially after a hurricane
amid the devastation is the desperation
crowds and cars lined up for gas in new
orleans
and i've been here since 10 o'clock it's
two thirds
this is time lapse video showing a line
of people waiting for food wrapping
around a block
hours before the food was even handed
out
many of the life-supporting
infrastructure elements are not present
they're not operating right now it's why
mike tragg sheriff of st john the
baptist parish keeps getting requests
for welfare checks
my father lives at this address in
laplace he's 77 years old
disabled male 1 that was a message from
a man in new jersey who wanted to know
that his dad is okay
so the sheriff sent his men to go check
and see cajun navy and the national
guard has not been able to make contact
with him due to bringing the roadway and
they went out
to check on him
sir 77 year old john moore was home
alone with his dog nixon all right we're
with the sheriff's office your son is
worried about you because he hasn't
heard from you
would you like to
choose all right would you like us to
get you out yes sir all right they found
that moore's house was damaged by ida no
water no food no electricity and no fuel
in his generator so the officers
convinced him it was not safe to stay
you know i tried to be by myself but
it's okay
it's 77 it's hard they helped moore who
has parkinson's to get dressed and
before they left officer joshua mathern
began folding an american flag that he
found on moore's bedroom floor
then they all escorted him to the
shelter we have your father your
father's fine we also have the dog
your father's a little shaken up just
wants to make sure he didn't do anything
wrong and he's going to be okay
lieutenant jake boudreau decided it was
safer for mr moore to go to the hospital
all right you're ready
apparently this is his father's flag
world war ii veteran kind of felt wrong
to leave it hanging on the ground and as
he sat on the stretcher
they handed him that flag
as mr moore was taken away nixon was
taken from him because they don't allow
dogs at the hospital
you know the sheriff's team was not
going to let lil nixon be abandoned so
lieutenant boudreau personally took
nixon to the emergency operations center
and he hand delivered him to rachel she
is the manager of the animal services
and rachel is personally going to look
after nixon and make sure he is okay
until he can be reunited with mr moore
gail
i don't even know where you get these
stories from david i'm just sitting here
thinking about nixon i'm thinking about
mr moore saying i'm worried about me too
i'm thinking about how mr moore just
fell into the arms of the of the soldier
or the the police official who came to
help him it's so touching on so many
levels but best of all now the son knows
that his dad is okay
i'm so proud to be from louisiana we
have some really good people here no
you're one of those good people yeah and
please stay away from the gators that's
something i hadn't thought about either
thank you david bagneau deal stellar
stellar as always we want you back